a horrific massacre of American citizens
takes place in the Mexican border state
of Sonora
new polls undercut Elizabeth Warren's
case for the nomination and the
Washington Nationals show Trump some
love I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn stop putting
your online data at risk get protected
at expressvpn comm slash Ben okay so the
big news of the morning is really
horrific news from the Mexican border
state of Sonora Mexico has been for a
very very long time a deeply hellacious
and violent place at least in certain
segments of the country there was just a
couple of years ago a massive
controversy over a study is in 2017
showing that Mexico is the deadly second
deadliest country in the world like more
deadly than every country other than
Syria that was an annual survey by the
International Institute for Strategic
Studies that showed that Mexico's death
toll was surpassed only by that in Syria
President Trump at the time retweeted a
link to a CNN article on the report
parts of Mexico according to the UK
Guardian have suffered horrific violence
since the then President Felipe Calderon
declared war on organized crime a decade
ago the struggle as of 2017 had claimed
an estimated 200,000 lives and left more
than 30,000 people missing that was of
two years ago so the numbers are much
larger now Mexico claims that large
swaths of the country are unaffected by
drug violence and I said well it's not
like Syria cuz the whole country there
is engulfed but the fact is that the the
country of Mexico has been plagued by
severe corruption issues by
extraordinary acts of violence in which
you will actually see mobile gangs of
cartels actually take over entire areas
of the country the country is is so
poorly governed that there there have
been serious questions about the
relationship between various
administrations in Mexico and the drug
cartels are the drug cartels paying for
those administrations are they the ones
really in control of the government can
Mexico actually control all this it
makes a pretty solid case for why there
should be a border wall for President
Trump well that case burst back out into
the open today after a horrific massacre
of nine Americans in Mexico we'll get to
that story in just one second first
let's talk about saving some money a
brighter note
the fact is that the holidays are
approaching and because the holidays are
approaching it's time for you to do a
little bit of holiday shopping but the
fact is that you can look for all the
discount codes you want and you probably
aren't gonna find all of them this is
why you ought to be using honey honey is
a free browser extension that
automatically finds the best promo codes
wherever you shop online you just load
it up and then it runs in the background
of your computer every time you shop
honey will provide you with discounts I
mean like almost literally every time
you shop i've saved probably hundreds of
dollars using honey already honey has
found it's over 10 million members over
a billion dollars in savings honey has
over a hundred thousand plus five star
reviews on the google chrome store it
works with all the sites including
amazon.com if you're buying gifts this
holiday season you need honey if you're
not you probably know somebody who is so
do the masala and tell them about honey
it's free to use it installs in just two
clicks get honey for free at join the
honey calm slash pen that's join honey
calm slash pen again honey can make sure
that you are getting the best price for
any item that you purchased check them
out right now at join honey calm slash
man and it's free so what exactly do you
have to lose and the answer is nothing
except for it you can lower your bill so
go check them out again right now join
honey calm slash man ok so here's the
story in the UK son babies were burned
alive after ruthless cartel killer
slaughtered nine us Mormons in a
targeted hit
in Mexico the victims were ambushed by
the merciless gunmen as they drove to a
wedding in the border state of Sonora on
Monday 17 members of the LeBaron and
Langford families were travelling in
three cars when gunmen sprayed their
vehicles with bullets some of the
victims including babies were then
reportedly burned alive amid fears
female victims were raped according to
the UK Daily Mail Alex LeBaron who said
he lost family members in the attack
told CNN women and children were
massacred burnt alive mothers were
screaming for the fire to stop several
family members have now told how gunmen
opened fire on one child running away
and revealed how others burned to death
inside a car that was torched other
young children managed to escape and
hide by the roadside while one of the
mothers was shot in the chest as she put
her hands up to surrender according to
the UK Sun survivors described how one
boy managed to hide his wounded siblings
some less than a year old in bushes
before he ran back to the nearby town to
get help others are still missing
sparking genuine concerns the death toll
in the wake of the atrocity will go up
it's unclear what motivated the killings
they took place on a dirt road between
Chihuahua and Sonora States but this is
not the first time that members of the
brick
Church have been attacked in northern
Mexico where their forebears settle
decades ago in 2009 Benjamin LeBaron and
anti-crime activist related to those
killed in Monday's attack was murdered
in neighboring Chihuahua state the
authorities are even investigating
whether the large family were mistaken
for a rival cartel gang security
minister Alfonso Durazo said that the
attack could have been a case of
mistaken identity between conflicting
groups in the area family members
believe it was a targeted kidnapping
after one relative reported receiving a
phone call hearing screams before they
were executed so this is just an
absolute horror show it was revealed
that one mother died saving her baby
during the bloodshed her name is
Christina Lange for Johnson 31 she was
among the three mothers and at least six
kids including twin babies who were
killed when the gunmen ambushed their
vehicles as they drove to a wedding in
northern at Mexico
Christina seven month old baby faith was
found alive on the floor in the back of
the Chevy Suburban relatives say the
infant was rescued after spending hours
inside the car with her mother's body so
just horrific horrific
ronita LeBaron 33 had broken down in her
SUV when gunmen opened fire torching the
vehicle causing the gas tank to explode
shoes found dead inside the
bullet-ridden car along with her
six-month-old babies Titus and Tiana two
have originated as other children
Krystle 10 in Howard 12 were also
reportedly killed in the attack eight
miles ahead Christina and Donna Langford
43 and 2 of Jonah's children Trevor and
Rogan three Trevor was 11 Rogan was
three were also killed in other SUVs
Donna's seven other children were shot
but survived according to claims and
further children are understood to be
missing after they escaped from the
flames and fled there's a video that was
posted on social media we did pull it
but we can't show it because it's just
too graphic for for Facebook or any of
the other places that air this show a
male voice in an American accent who's
reported relative he says this is for
the record Nita and four of my
grandchildren are burnt and shot up all
the victims lived in a Mormon community
in Lemoore about 70 miles south of
Douglas Arizona they had dual US and
Mexican citizenship some of their
community worship with the Church of
Jesus Christ of latter-day saints a
Mormon others are from polygamous
offshoots of the Mormon Church Leah
Stanton who grew up in the same Mormon
community said her brother found one of
the bullet written cars with charred
bodies inside just absolutely horrific
horrific one of the relatives said the
victims were innocent were caught up in
a war involving rival drug cartels
President Trump
immediately
got involved he suggested that it may be
time for the United States to get
involved he tweeted out a wonderful
family and friends from Utah got caught
between two vicious drug cartels who
were shooting at each other with the
result being many great American people
killed including young children and some
missing if a minute if Mexico needs or
requests help in cleaning out these
monsters the United States stands ready
willing and able to get involved and do
the job quickly and effectively the
great new president of Mexico has made
this a big issue but the cartels have
become so large and powerful you
sometimes need an army to defeat an army
this is the time for Mexico with the
help of the United States to wage war on
the drug cartels and wipe them off the
face of the earth we merely a way to
call from your great new president now
the response from the media has
obviously been somewhat subdued because
on the one hand they don't want Trump to
build a wall on the other hand they
don't want Trump to get involved in
fighting the Mexican drug cartels and
you really cannot have it both ways if
there's a third solution that some in
the libertarian movement have proposed
which is legalizing drugs and the
American side of the border thus
quashing the demand for drug cartels on
the Mexican side of the border you
legalize it all this becomes mainstream
you can have actual legal farms that
produce all of this stuff but the fact
is that people who are in the drug
industry in Mexico are not going to turn
to banking if things change in the
United States they're gonna continue to
find other ways of involving themselves
in lucrative illegal activity that's why
they move from for example marijuana
over to harder drugs as the United
States became more accustomed to
marijuana
wherever the profit is is where the drug
cartels are going to move the bigger
issue in Mexico is the fact that the
administration of Mexico this has been
true for decades at this point they're
stuck between a little bit of a rock and
a hard place on the one hand some of
these presidents presumably would like
to see the drug cartels go on the other
hand if they call in the United States
to help them which really is in may be
the only option here then they could
immediately be ousted by the people of
Mexico who are not particularly fond of
America getting involved in Mexican
politics the last time the United States
got militarily involved in Mexico is
1914 when the United States invaded
Veracruz and that didn't go particularly
well for either the United States or
Mexico so what exactly is the solution
this well the first solution obviously
is yes there needs to be a wall we do
not want this stuff crossing America
southern border leaving a broad swaths
of the American southern border open
drug cartels who are using those borders
as thoroughfares for guns drugs human
trafficking it's unthinkable really it's
unthinkable
I mean if Trump cannot make the case for
a border wall in the aftermath of an
attack like this then it's very
difficult to imagine how he could make
the case for a border wall and if
Democrats can make a case against a
border wall in the aftermath of an
attack like this they're gonna have to
explain why and if they say well all
this is just happening in Mexico it's
not crossing the border yeah talk to
people who are living in some of the
border cities where there is no barrier
legs easy to say El Paso is doing well
right El Paso has a wall if you look at
some of the border areas in Mexico rates
of violence have skyrocketed thanks to
the involvement of the drug cartels now
the fact is that the United States has
long considered the possibility of
having to get involved in merit
militarily to help out the Mexican
government but as I say the Mexican
government has proved itself unwilling
to actually move forward with anything
remotely like that in fact the current
President of Mexico Andres Manuel Lopez
Lopez Obrador who is a member of the
political left there he has what he is
called the hugs not bullets policy with
regard to the cartels
meaning you're trying to work with them
you don't try to get violent with them
and that merely escalates the situation
well that isn't working either
it turns out that the only way to wipe
out actual criminal cartels is to kill
members of the actual criminal cartels
as I say case we made for legalization
of drugs in the United States that would
presumably lower the market for these
drug cartels in the first place and
lower their power by extension but
that's not gonna happen anytime soon
particularly with some of the harder
drugs that we're talking about in the
middle of an opioid epidemic and the
fact is that a lot of these drug cartels
are trafficking in precisely the kinds
of opioids particularly heroin black tar
heroin
that have caused the opioid epidemic to
break out with such viciousness in the
United States leading to tens of
thousands of lost lives in the United
States just a few days ago just a few
days ago the UK Guardian reported that
manuel lopez obrador
is under sustained pressure to rethink
his non-confrontational security
strategy amid lingering questions over
the botched arrest of the son of el
chapo guzman well that's that in just
one second first let's talk for a second
about political coverage there's a world
of fake
news out there controversy is just
constant all the time but in politics
here's the reality when everybody says
well things have never been as bad as
this before it's like well just take a
look at America's history follow along
from ballot to fallout in podcasting
networks
sizzling new podcast political scandals
which will remind you that yeah we've
had some scandals before every Tuesday
leading up to the 2020 election
political scandals will count down the
52 most scandalous events in American
history uncovering the ugly truth behind
some of our most infamous elected
officials each episode will tithe into a
different rise and fall exploring the
impact it had on the careers involved
and the lasting effects on American
history from Watergate and Lewinsky to
Chappaquiddick and the 2000 recount dig
deeper into the stories you thought you
knew or had no idea had changed the
state of American politics red state
blue state left or right none of these
scandals are off-limits on the new
podcast series political scandals it's
free on Spotify or wherever you get your
podcast or visit podcast.com slash
political scandals to listen now so I'm
just one remind yourself that things can
always be worse listen to this podcast
political scandals remind yourself that
America we've had these issues before
podcast.com slash a political scandal so
as I say the UK Guardian is reporting
that openeth aura is already under
serious pressure to rethink his strategy
with regardeth cartels or video Guzman
was briefly held in the northern city of
Culiacan last month but was freed after
hundreds of gunmen launched a wave of
attacks on security forces and blocked
roads with burning vehicles the show of
strength shots even the most hardened
observers have organized crime in Mexico
is my heart quois editor of the
investigative Sinaloa weekly rio dulce
described the moment as a watershed he
said life goes on yes but not in the
same way we don't know if this will now
be the reaction every time criminal
groups feel threatened we know even less
what the federal government intends to
do about it the President of Mexico
insists the incident marks a turning
point away from the punitive policies of
his two predecessors he says this is no
longer war it is no longer about forced
confrontation anihilation extermination
or killing in the heat of the moment
they said this is about thinking how to
save lives and achieve peace and
tranquility in the country using other
methods he says those other methods are
social programs to alleviate extreme
poverty yeah good luck with that I'm
sorry but if you think that social
programs are going to alleviate the fact
that the most profitable enterprises in
Mexico right now are these drug cartels
yeah sure sure he says that
exportations to a good behavior and the
insistency is now banned corruption will
help
he has also pledged to offer what he
calls a Brazos no bolaños hugs not
bullets
yeah hugs for the people who are
shooting down tens of thousands of
Mexican citizens and who just shot nine
American citizens as well and burn them
to death and maybe rape them he's also
created a new militarized national
police force though this has not yet
taken a significant role in operations
against organized crimes the problem
according to security experts again this
is the UK Guardian reporting is there
nothing in open-door strategy directly
addresses the terrifying power of the
country's criminal underworld which was
brazenly displayed on October 17th even
before troops detained Guzman convoys of
heavily armed cartel gunmen were
speeding to strategic positions in and
around the city the effort to rescue
Guzman held the city hostage but also
targeted the military's weakest points
such as buildings where soldiers
families live what we saw in Culiacan
was the parallel state showing itself
said Edgardo boo Scalia an expert on
organized crime at Columbia University
woo Scalia broadly agreed with obradors
critique of his predecessors but argued
that fighting poverty cannot alone end
criminality many countries far poorer
than Mexico suffer far less from
organized crime instead the government
has to start with a concerted strategy
to dismantle the entrenched political
and business interest with protection
which protect and profit from organized
crime what a Lopez Obrador needs is not
a security strategy he said what he
needs is an anti mafia strategy but
again the problem is that there may not
be the institutional power necessary at
the level of the federal government in
Mexico to actually take care of this
problem a lot of the federal
institutions have been honeycombed with
at with with advocates for the cartels
with people who work with the cartels
police forces in Mexico have long been
plagued with serious corruption problems
people who are working for the cartel as
well
simultaneously supposedly working for
the police there there are a lot of
people who are --court of course again
suggesting American involvement but it's
difficult to imagine obrador actually
calling for America to get involved at
this point which again leaves Trump with
virtually no alternative to the building
of the wall right I mean this is the
point you can't let that violence spread
north into the United States it's a
horrifying horrifying story there's no
easy solution and I'm waiting for
solutions from the left
involved building a wall and if you say
just send more money to the Mexican
government we have been sending billions
of dollars to the Mexican government we
do enormous amounts of trade with the
Mexican government presumably designed
to actually - to actually strengthen the
federal government in their capacity to
fight all of this but that hasn't helped
and it's gonna continue not helping so
long as the Mexican drug cartels
maintain this enormous sort of power in
the United States when we had a mafia
problem we had to activate the federal
government on a massive level to destroy
the Mafia in the United States and to
destroy the various alcohol cartels that
existed during Prohibition we really
really activate activated you know every
resource at our disposal
the Mexican government may not actually
have those resources at their disposal
so I'm waiting to hear solutions people
can rip on Trump for being if we're
going off half-cocked with regards to
these tweets but I'm not seeing any
other solutions I really am not a wall
or answering Mexico's call for aid those
would be the only two solutions that are
truly on the table at this point now
meanwhile there are Brandt a bunch of
brand new poles some good for Trump some
bad for from the national polling is not
particularly good for Trump the State
polling however is actually quite good
for Trump and that radically reshift s--
the nature of the of the 2020
presidential race now that this attack
in Mexico should remind people that it's
a cruel world out there a cold world out
there and that the sort of open borders
policy of the Democratic Party is not
something the United States should be
accepting under any circumstances the
same Democratic Party saying they want
to decriminalize border crossing not at
ports of entry they want to
decriminalize that make that not a crime
anymore the same party that says we
don't need a wall with Mexico do you
want to give them power is that
truthfully something that you want to do
like this is where Trump really should
be pushing okay but in the new national
polling according to the Washington Post
Dan Balz and Scott Clement reporting one
year from the 2020 election President
Trump trails him potential Democratic
rivals in head-to-head matchups his
national support level is fixed at about
40 percent according to a Washington
post/abc News poll the new poll
highlights the degree to which most of
the country already has made a judgement
about the president's performance and
his voting preferences next year among
the 39 percent of registered voters who
approve of Trump's job performance from
winning at least 95 support 95% support
against each of five possible Democratic
opponents but among the 58 percent of
voters who disapprove of Trump he
receives no more than 7% of support
Biden Sanders and Warren run strongest
against the president nationally
according to this new poll the new poll
has Biden up 17 points 56 239 war and 15
points 55 to 40 and Sanders up 55 to 41
Pete Budaj
leads 52 to 41 Harris 51 to 42 again in
all of these numbers from stuck
somewhere between 39 and 42 percent but
those were the same numbers that we saw
in the run up to the 2016 election as
well we kept seeing Trump stuck in the
low 40s and then he performed at about
47% in the national election which was
enough to win him the presidency the
poll reflects national findings but
other state surveys have shown tighter
races particularly in the swing states
Republicans and Democrats are mostly
locked into their voting intentions but
what these polls tend to shows that
independents are moving away from Trump
but that may not be the case in the near
future if again Democrats continue to be
as radical as they are and this is what
we are seeing in the swing states well
get to the swing state poll that came
out from the New York Times it's
devastating for Elizabeth Warren's case
for being the presidential nominee we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about your sleep quality so I
am back from Israel I'm back in the
United States not only does that mean
that I'm out a better mattress than I
was in Israel not only does it mean I'm
back home which is awesome it also means
that my sleep quality is getting better
thanks to the fact that I am now back on
the softest sheets available I'm talking
about bull and branch eats everything
bull and branch makes from bedding to
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton they start out super soft they
get even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to $1,000 in the store but
bull and branch sheets are only a couple
of hundred bucks shipping is free you
can try them for 30 nights there's no
risk and no reason not to give them a
try try bull and branch sheets today I
promise you'll love them they're so good
that my wife and I we got the Bolin
brand sheets then we threw out all of
our other sheets it made it almost
impossible to sleep on those crap sheets
that we got at the local retailer to get
you started right now my listeners get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets at
bull and branch com promo code Ben go to
bull and branch calm today for 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets that's a
bol and branch calm promo code Ben bull
and branch
komm promo code ban go check them out
right now and when he used that promo
clip Benton get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets which is an awesome deal
bull and branch comm promo code events
as I say the national polls for Trump
are not looking particularly good the
state polls for Trump are a different
story
so among likely voters there's a poll
came out from the New York Times
yesterday the New York Times in Siena
College and here is what it found and
found the Joe Biden was up very slightly
in Michigan Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Florida in Arizona and down slightly in
North Carolina all of this within the
margin of error it shows that Bernie
Sanders was ahead in Michigan by three
but behind Trump in all of those other
swing states and here is the kicker it
shows that Elizabeth Warren is down to
trump in every single swing state all of
them according to the New York Times
Siena College poll it shows Warren down
four in Michigan down two and
Pennsylvania down two in Wisconsin down
four in Florida even in Arizona down
four in North Carolina which shows again
that the national polling numbers are
less indicative of where this race is
going then those state polling numbers
people can say this thing is over
Trump's done he's toast but that's not
the reality and Elizabeth Warren I think
she set up for a fall here I think she
is I mean remember at the same time that
we are seeing American citizens being
slaughtered just south of the American
border and Democrats are trying to say
that there shouldn't be a wall the
Democrats are also trying to claim that
America's foreign policy is deeply
egregious for example just to give an
example why why is Elizabeth Warren set
up for fall again her case has to be
that she is electable but if she's not
perceived as electable then she's
basically toast right now she is
coasting on months of positive media
coverage but I don't know how long
that's gonna last as the American people
see her I mean for example yesterday
Elizabeth Warren was doing a Q&A and
some radical leftist got up and
suggested that the American government
supports genocide and Elizabeth Warren
not at along with this here is this
bizarre exchange
[Applause]
[Music]
little ears high since we want to be a
great nation lead the world then we need
to live our values every single I like
your take on this he literally said that
America supports genocide and not only
Yemen but quote-unquote Palestine by the
way if you think there's a genocide in
Palestine I urge you to go visit
Palestine okay a state that does not
exist it's like Narnia but I urge you to
go visit the Palestinian territories
where the population has been growing
hand over fist
I mean rapidly there's some five to six
million Palestinians who are now living
in the West the so-called West Bank and
the Gaza Strip
that's the worst genocide of all time
but Elizabeth Warren just humorous that
kind of stuff so in a threatening world
in a world of actual threats are people
gonna turn to Elizabeth Warren and as it
turns out Elizabeth Warren's plans our
garbage too so if she's not perceived as
likable if she's not perceived as
credible if she's not perceived as able
to beat Trump you could start to see the
media turn away from her and again the
hits keep on coming with regard to the
medicare-for-all plan that she released
over the weekend
I mean even other Democrats are looking
at her and crossing their eyes for
example Steven Rattner was a counselor
to the Treasury Secretary in the Obama
administration's he's a lifelong
Democrat he has a piece in The New York
Times today called the warren way is the
wrong way he says senator Elizabeth
Warren has unveiled her vision for how
to pay for Medicare for all a daunting
mountain of new taxes and fees thanks
for providing us miss Warren with yet
more evidence that Warren presidency is
a terrifying prospect one brought closer
by your surge in the polls left to her
own devices should extend the reach and
weight of the federal government far
further into the economy than anything
even President Franklin Roosevelt
imagined effectively abandoning the
limited government model that is mostly
served as well miss Warren may call
herself a capitalist or her panoply of
minutely detailed plans suggests
otherwise again this is an Obama
official she would turn America's
uniquely successful public-private
relationship into a good Duras tea
european-style system if you want to
live in France economically Elizabeth
Warren should be your candidate he says
as a life law
Democrat I freely acknowledge that
substantial reforms are much needed both
to achieve a more equitable distribution
of income and wealth and to make good on
Donald Trump's failed pledge to raise
the economy's growth way rate but the
warren way would be quite simply the
wrong way today public attention has
understandably focused on miss Warren
support for Medicare for all as well as
her long list of other new social
programs like the green New Deal free
college tuition universal hot childcare
student debt forgiveness and on and on
Armada of changes would be highly
disruptive for example to the 156
million Americans who have private
health insurance and expensive at least
twenty three four trillion dollars over
the next decade by the way it's not 23
trillion dollars over the next decade it
is it is more like 50 trillion dollars
over the next decade if you're including
the already present spending with regard
to health care in the United States she
wants to expand new taxes increasing
federal revenues by more than 50 percent
plus she wants to impose vast new
regulatory burdens and she's also lying
about all of this
she's also a lot I mean her proposals
are fully insane and Steven Rattner
points out that workers would occupy 40
percent of board seats another page out
of the failed European playbook even
Germany has had a significantly slower
growth rate than ours for many years
because of this sort of stuff and then
she wants the Department of Economic
Development charged with creating and
defending good American jobs but really
this is the government trying to pick
winners and losers and raise tariffs and
then she wants new committees to allow
consumers and rural areas to delayed
trade deals that worry them it's just a
disaster
so Wratten are going after her okay the
fact is by the way that hurt hurt again
her Medicare for all plan is just a
perfect window into the the bizarre mind
of Elizabeth Warren according to reason
calm Reason magazine her plans who
financed Medicare for all at a total
price tag of nearly 52 trillion dollars
including about 20 trillion dollars of
new government spending an estimate that
is probably low she keeps saying that
she's not going to increase middle class
taxes but that's obviously Falls for
example the the chief trick that she
plays when she proposes Medicare for all
is that she says that the the employee
based insurance program so your employer
bit pays in and then you pay in my your
employer pays in may be 8% you pay in
maybe 7% and that pays for your health
care she's just gonna
take all that and turn that into attacks
that goes to the federal government
that's called the tax now people may say
well it doesn't come out of my bottom
line well it does because see here's the
thing your employer based health care
insurance is actually good Medicare not
nearly as good
so she's just converting private
expenditures into attacks and then not
calling it attacks and she refers to it
as an employer Medicare contribution
it's voluntary now sure that that is in
fact attacks obviously speaking also she
is she's counting on insane statistics
so for example she says that we are
going to increase IRS enforcement on
billionaires and she says that would
generate 55 billion dollars in revenue
over a decade okay she says that we
generate I'm sorry wrong five hundred
and fifty billion dollars in revenue
over the decade maybe two trillion two
point three trillion dollars I'm getting
this wrong again two point three
trillion dollars in additional federal
revenue just by staffing up the IRS okay
that is 40 times the estimate by the
Congressional Budget Office so she's
just falsifying all of this stuff it's
just sheer absolute nonsense The Wall
Street Journal editorial boy board
points this out they say she has 30
trillion dollars to finance but Warren
waves for one and says the bill will
really be 21 trillion she makes the rest
vanish by positing magical savings from
things like comprehensive payment reform
she says hospitals would be reimbursed
at an average of 110 percent of current
Medicare rates but hospitals now rely on
private insurance which would be gone in
the future also she says she's gonna
restore health care competition by what
abolishing health care competition in a
word she wants rationing which is not a
shock that is where all of this is going
so as we see these polls in the swing
states that show Warren trailing Trump
you could see a move away from Elizabeth
Warren and back to wait for it Joe Biden
I'll get to a new poll in Nevada that
shows that's exactly what is happening
in just one second first let's talk
about staying in shape now you may have
noticed that Shapiro lately it looked
like you've lost a little bit of weight
and he hadn't comments around the office
me too
but just bear with me the fact is that
if you want to lose weight if you want
to look better there is a great way to
do it and that is to use the new map
khanoom is just fantastic Noom gives you
specific goals you want to achieve
it's not just losing weight it helps you
achieve like it in a natural proper
balance of exercise and diet it teaches
you information about how you can break
your habits new is all about changing
your habits structure and when you are
talking about losing weight or being
more healthy it is changing that habit
structure that actually matters it's
based in psychology Noom teaches you why
you do the things you do and arms you
with the tools to break the bad habits
and replace them with better ones
Newman's a diet it's a healthy easy to
stick to way of life instead of making
food good or bad or off-limits Noom
teaches moderation which actually makes
it livable and can be used in
conjunction with many pre-existing
popular diets if you actually want you
don't have to change it all in one day
new makes it easy to do this day by day
and make your life better go check them
out right now at n oom comm slash
Shapiro you have nothing to lose except
the weight
visit numa comm slash Shapiro to start
that trial today again that's Noom comm
slash up here what's the last
weight-loss program you will ever need
okay more on the on the possible fading
of Elizabeth Warren we'll get to that in
just one second but first you're gonna
have to go and subscribe over at daily
wire.com $9.99 a month gets you the
subscription $99 a year gets to you the
annual subscription if you're not
already a subscriber you're really
missing out head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe for as little
as ten bucks a month you get our
articles at free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content our exclusive daily
wear app which is a pretty great feature
if you haven't checked it out yet you
can chat with me if you choose the
all-new all-access plan you'll get that
plus the legendary leftist ears tumblr
and our brand new ask me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our host writers and special
guests on a weekly basis so stop
depriving yourself come join the fun
today over at daily wire.com we always
appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
you
okay so as I say when it comes to
Elizabeth Warren what you may see in the
near future is Joe Biden starting to
recover in some of the in some of the
early states so her entire campaign
right now is staked on Iowa and New
Hampshire Buddha judge is making some
serious moves in Iowa if he takes Iowa
and Warren takes New Hampshire Biden is
still very much in the race because at
that point it's sort of a split and a
three-way race benefits the person who
is the biggest name and right now Biden
is continuing to hold a 10-point lead
over Warren and Bernie Sanders among
likely Democratic presidential caucus
goers in Nevada and that is buoyed by
the fact that people want somebody who
can be Trump the poll found that the
former vice president's lead narrows to
between three and four points among
respondents who described themselves as
being strongly committed to their first
choice candidate and identified either
Warren or Sanders as their top second
choice picked for the presidency
indicating that the race is far from
settled
but again the more people see of
Elizabeth Warren the less they like
Elizabeth Warren and I think that is a
trend that is likely to continue over
time
she's pretty terrible she's pretty
terrible and Bernie Sanders is gonna go
on Elizabeth Warren right now she's the
front-runner and she's the front-runner
early that means that Bernie Sanders
gonna turn his guns on her it means P
Budaj ad she's gonna turn his guns on
her means Biden will turn his guns on
her it means Kamala Harris will turn her
guns on her so things are gonna get ugly
for Warren here pretty quickly they take
for example Bernie Sanders Sanders is
looking at Warren and saying why is she
getting all the attention she steals my
ideas and then she lies about my ideas
and Here I am guys you want you want the
real deal you want the real deal you
want some pudding come to me free
pudding and also socialism here at a
Bernie Sanders headquarters but at least
Sanders is honest he says listen I'm not
gonna lie to you and tell you Medicare
for all is gonna be free we are getting
rid of the profiteering and the
corruption in the health care industry
the drug companies and the insurance
companies will be able to provide all of
that to people at a fraction of the cost
they are paying right now not here to
tell you it's going to be free enough to
pay something but it's gonna be a heck
of a lot less than what you're currently
paying I mean there's Bernie at least be
more honest about all of this I think
that Elizabeth Warren who's a media
creation there's a possibility she
starts to fall apart somewhere in her
okay other big news of the day so a
couple of pieces
of big news so our friend James O'Keefe
the the undercover journalist of a
project Veritas he has now gotten hold
of tape of an ABC News anchors hang on
an open-mic Rinna's amy robach and she
was caught on camera slamming her own
network for allegedly sitting on the
Jeffrey Epstein story three years ago
here's a little bit of what that sounded
like it's pretty incredible actually
pictures she had everything she was in
hiding for 12 years we convinced her to
come out we convinced her to talk to us
it was unbelievable what we had Clinton
we had everything I had for three years
to get it on to no avail and now it's
all coming out and it's like these new
relevant relationships were coming out
about Jeffrey Epstein because I had this
years ago and ABC News quashed it and
sat on it and now she has issued a
statement robots I mean it just shows
you how the media works bad look for the
media right in the aftermath of NBC News
basically quashing the Harvey Weinstein
story for years until Ronan Farrow broke
it and now it appears that ABC News was
sitting on the Jeffrey Epstein stuff for
years these are the media you're going
to trust and then the public trust in
the media is already at an all-time low
this is certainly not going to help nor
should it robot said her comments were
made quote in a private moment of
frustration I was upset that an
important interview I had conducted with
the Virginia Roberts didn't air because
we could not obtain corroborating
evidence to meet ABC's editorial
standards about her allegations
regarding Jeffrey Epstein Prince Andrew
and Bill Clinton she added that in the
years since the 2015 interview no one
ever told me or the team to stop
reporting on Jeffrey Epstein and we have
continued to aggressively pursue this
important story and ABC News statement
issued says at the time not all of our
reporting met our standards to air but
we have never stopped investigating the
story well yet kind of didn't you I mean
just a little bit I mean the fact is
that if it didn't meet your standards to
air well then presumably you should have
kept digging
presumably you should have kept digging
so that is a that is a pretty it's it's
a pretty damning indictment of ABC News
and that's not what she's saying there
right I mean what what she is saying in
that clip is that she had the interview
she had the goods
she has pictures there so it's different
than then what she is saying in her
statement her same and she's like oh
well we didn't have all the goods but
math in that tape she's saying yeah we
pretty much had all of the goods if the
media was involved in in covering up or
at least neglecting to investigate
Jeffrey Epstein because they thought
that it was going to hurt the Clintons
that's a massive massive story obviously
and goes again to the level of media
bias that is involved in all of this
pretty astonishing ramallah Hemingway
over at the over at the Federalist she
she tweets in addition to these
statements not actually being responsive
to what the initial hot mic claims were
mostly what this shows that ABC News has
an in defensively different standard for
eg the Kavanaugh allegations or for the
Covington boys than it does for Clinton
connected pedophiles which is of course
exactly right they're willing to run
with any level of speculation including
false speculation about anything about
anything that's that hurts Republicans
but if it could possibly dam the
Clintons then all of a sudden they run
away from this stuff like wholesale and
then you wonder why the American people
have trouble trusting the media that
would be the reason speaking of the
media by the way they went nuts
yesterday because President Trump hosted
the Washington Nationals at the White
House and obviously this was a disaster
I mean then the media only likes sports
teams that boycott Trump's White House
yesterday at the White House Trump
hosted the Washington National that a
bunch of a bunch of members of the
Nationals are actually Trump fans which
is not really a shock if you look at
it's sort of the political breakdown of
various sports leagues the NBA is
obviously the most anti Trump the NFL is
somewhere in the middle the MLB Major
League Baseball tends to be probably
majority Pro Trump more of a Republican
League more of a conservative League at
least in terms of the players and the
NHL I believe tends to be overwhelmingly
overwhelmingly more conservative and
that's none of that as a particular shot
given the polarized racial politics of
the country right now but the media went
nuts because some of the Washington
Nationals players were committing the
great and evil sin of wearing Magga hat
so Kurt Suzuki who's the catcher for the
Washington Nationals he put on a Maggie
had here is what that looked like
where's
come in say a couple words come on I
[Applause]
love you all I love you all thank you
how dare he wear a Maggie had the media
went nuts over all this Ryan Zimmerman
who plays third base for the Washington
Nationals he also got up there and he
thanked President Trump which of course
is terrible it's one thing if you
ordered the White House and you praised
Barack Obama if you praise Trump this is
obviously a terrible terrible thing
here's Ryan Zimmerman thanking Trump
yesterday mr. president me and my
teammates first of all like to thank you
for having us here this is a is an
incredible honor that I think all of us
all will never will never forget and I
would also like to thank you for keeping
everyone here safe in our country and
continuing to make America the greatest
country to live in the world
terrible terrible terrible this prompted
a spasm of stupidity from the left-wing
outlet called Palmer report on Twitter
talking about how wearing a mag ahead is
basically like being a Nazi this Palmer
report person said putting on a mega hat
is a form of racist hate speech and an
implicit threat of violence implicit
threat of violence Kurt Suzuki should be
banned from baseball if you don't like
this tweet fu so just to be straight if
you wear a mag I hat you should be
banned from baseball entirely my
favorite was mad Iglesias tweeted out
about this he was like well there are a
lot of white non-college educated
players in the MLB Ryan Zimmerman went
to University of Virginia and Kurt
Suzuki is not white so a couple of basic
category errors in all of this now the
fact is that Democrats are not taking
into account the backlash that is going
to attend to the to the insanity of the
radical left attitude to the insanity of
Elizabeth Warren's the insanity of
Bernie Sanders President Trump held a
rally last night and his basic point is
going to play well as I keep saying if
President Trump simply campaigns simply
campaigns on pointing his finger at the
Democrats he'll probably be okay
he'll probably be okay I mean here was
president Trump yesterday at a rally
explaining the Democratic agenda with
regard to indoctrinating American kids
they want to indoctrinate your children
you know this destroy anyone who holds
traditional American values all you have
to do is ask the boys from Covington
Catholic High School some of whom are
here tonight the far-left wants to
impose their authoritative ideology on
the nation telling you what to think
what to believe and how you should live
okay and he's exactly right about all
this and then they lie about it right
Joy Behar let the cat out of the bag
yesterday on the view
she said yeah that's kind of what we
want to do all those things but we have
to keep it kind of a secret guys that's
that's really what we have to do is keep
it a secret tell everything they're
gonna do like if you're gonna take
people's guns away wait till you get
elected then take the guns
[Applause]
people like me think's gonna happen okay
but with all of that said right I mean
this is the reason I mean Megan McCain
is right over there we can read between
the lines guys we know exactly what it
is that you are doing and so Democrats
have been forced as I keep saying over
and over and this this is the feeling I
think the American people additional are
increasingly getting the feeling that
the reason Democrats are so focused in
on impeachment is not because they
believe that Trump did anything
extraordinarily vile are terrible in
Ukraine anything so beyond the pale it's
because they think that if they don't
impeach Trump and sully him in some new
and unforeseen way then he will win
reelection right that that that is
obviously what is in Democrats Minds now
what that said there are some updates on
the progression of the investigation so
Democrats have been releasing the
transcript of some of the conversations
they've been had in the Intelligence
Committee yesterday they're released
House transcripts with former ambassador
to Ukraine at Mary Ivanovitch as well as
ambassador Michael McKinley who's a
senior aide to Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo and none of these transcripts
look good for Trump but none of them
actually uncover criminal activity and
none of these transcripts are wonderful
looking but none of them actually
suggests that Trump was involved in the
sort of criminal and pupil activity that
Democrats have been claiming and so
Democrats are looking for new sources
one of the sources they're counting on
and and they're very excited about this
his love Parnas he's an invited
Ukrainian American businessman who has
ties to president Trump's personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani
according to Reuters he is now prepared
to comply with requests for records and
testimony from congressional impeachment
investigators according to his lawyer
harness helped Giuliani look for dirt on
Trump's political rival former Vice
President Joe Biden and he's a key
figure in this impeachment inquiry
because presumably Parnas could
theoretically testify that Giuliani
wasn't concerned about overwhelming
corruption in Ukraine he wasn't
interested in buries m'a he wasn't
interested in generalized Ukrainian
corruption partners could say maybe
second hand that Giuliani had said Trump
wants to get bide and help me out and so
partners could be a difficult witness
against Trump now it is also true that
Parnas is currently under indictment so
that means that he is not the most
trustworthy witness you could end up
with a Michael Cohen problem for
Democrats which is Michael Cohen
is indicted he's gonna go to jail and
suddenly he swivels and he starts
singing like a bird and everybody's like
well can we believe them now because it
seems like he has something to gain out
of all of this according to reuters
Parnas his apparent decision to work
with the congressional committees
represents a change of heart
Pyrus rebuffed a request from three
House of Representatives committees last
month to provide documents and testimony
his lawyer said quote we will honor and
not avoid the committee's requests the
extent they are legally proper while
scrupulously protecting mr. Parnassus
privileges including that of the Fifth
Amendment Giuliani has not immediately
responded to requests for comment on
Capitol Hill
the white house the house leadership and
a spokesperson for the House
Intelligence Committee declined comment
as well but juxtaposed all of that with
a new report from John Solomon I mean
all of this is turning into a mask as
you would predict John Solomon who has
done a heavy amounts of lifting over at
the hill Democrats hate him the media
hate him because he keeps pointing out
that there may have actually been some
there there with regard to Biden
corruption he has a story today over
John Solomon reports calm the headline
is hunter Biden's Ukraine gasp firm
pressed Obama administration to end
corruption allegations memos show so in
other words it sounds like maybe
something really did corrupt and
investigate able was was happening in
Ukraine according to John Solomon hunter
Biden and his Ukrainian gas from
colleagues had multiple contacts with
the Obama State Department during the
2016 election cycle including one just a
month before VP Joe Biden forced Ukraine
to fire the prosecutor investigating his
son's company for corruption newly
released memos show during that February
2016 contact a US Representative for
Purisima Holdings sought a meeting with
the Undersecretary of state Catherine
Novelli
to discuss ending the corruption
allegations against the Ukrainian firm
where hunter Biden worked as a board
member
according to memos obtained under a
Freedom of Information Act lawsuit just
three weeks before buries ms overture to
state ukrainian authorities raided the
home of the oligarch who owned the gas
firm and employed hunter Biden a signal
the long-running corruption probe was
escalating in the middle of the u.s.
presidential election hunter Biden's
name in fact was specifically invoked by
the burries me representative as the
reason the State Department should help
according to a series of email exchanges
among US officials trying to arrange the
meeting the subject line for the email
exchanges at read simply Purisima quote
per our conversation Karen from Montana
of Bluestar strategies requested a
meeting to discuss with us a Novelli USG
remarks alleging Purisima of corruption
said a february 24th 2016 email between
state officials she noted that two
high-profile US citizens are affiliated
with the company including hunter Biden
as a board member from Montana would
like to talk with the US about getting a
better understanding of how the US came
to the determination that the company is
corrupt according to tramonto no there's
no evidence of corruption has been no
hearing a process and evidence to the
contrary has been considered so all of
this stinks at least a little bit the
emails show that this person from
Montana was scheduled to meet with
Novelli on March 1st 2016 and at State
Department officials were scrambling to
get answers ahead of time from the US
Embassy in Kiev so if it appears that
hunter Biden's company Purisima is
pressuring the Obama administration to
drum to drop the investigation the
months leading up to Joe Biden
pressuring Ukraine to dump its
prosecutor it's not a great look right
there not a great look so if all of this
ends up basically coming down to a
partisan fight this isn't gonna damage
Trump in the end at all and it will come
back to the electability of President
Trump versus the electability of Joe
Biden or Elizabeth Warren okay time for
a quick thing that I like and then a
quick thing that I hate so things that I
like today Paul Johnson is one my
favorite historians he's a wonderful
historian his book modern times is one
of the great sort of comprehensive
histories of the of the early 20th
century and late 19th century
he has another book that's not quite as
well read called the birth of the modern
world Society 1815 to 1830 and you think
to yourself what the hell happened 1815
1830 it turns out a lot and the book
also covers sort of the periods slightly
before 1815 and the period slightly
after 1830 but it is amazing how many of
the arguments were having today do have
roots in this period the book is really
first-rate I really enjoy as I say Paul
Johnson's work I think he's terrific
check it out the birth of the modern it
is a heavy read okay this thing is like
a thousand pages but come on you have
time go check it out the birth of the
modern by Paul Johnson okay time for a
quick thing that I hate
one of the reasons why so many Americans
think the Democrats are radical is
because on issues like abortion they've
gotten more radical over time in their
language has gotten more radical over
time take for example this Pennsylvania
State Representative her name her name
is Wendy Ullman she's a Democrat from
Bucks Pennsylvania and she was making a
speech about anti-abortion laws when she
dropped this bizarre line about
miscarriage also talking about a woman
who comes into the facility and is
having cramps and they're not to be not
to be concrete an early miscarriage is
just some mess on a on a napkin and I'm
not sure people would agree that this is
something that we want to take to the
point of ritual okay an early
miscarriage is just a mess on a napkin
really that sort of language is what
Democrats want to run up she's come
forward now and she's apologized she
said many women and family find
tremendous comfort and solace in ritual
burial or cremation in the case of early
miscarriages others do not
some would choose donation for medical
research like my family friend who I
quoted in a committee meeting saying so
my loss can have meaning what she's
speaking against was a Pennsylvania
House bill that would require abortion
clinics and healthcare facilities to
bury or cremate lost unborn children as
opposed to tossing out the kids like
routine medical waste so she used that
sort of language she's not the only
democratic representative who's using
that sort of language of Virginia
senator is is also using language that
is quite bizarre saying don't worry guys
you know the real reason that men care
about abortion is because women are the
ones who have abortions this Virginia
state senator says if men were the ones
having abortion sort of stuff is so
irritating if men were the ones having
abortion then there would be an abortion
clinic on every street corner
to access abortion process okay and that
got big cheers
his name is dicks a sloth at that state
representative which doesn't that
undercut its argument isn't the argument
that men are terrible and bad and men
are terrible and bad and thus they would
be having more abortions than women okay
well that's sort of a sort of a pro-life
argument like it maybe that's true maybe
if men could get abortions that they
would be pushing for more abortion but
that sort of suggests the immorality of
abortion doesn't it not the not the
wonderful the sort of wonderful generous
nature of abortion okay we'll be back
here later today with all the additional
updates on the situation over in Mexico
on the presidential race we have a lot
more news to cover a little bit later
today so stick around for that two
additional hours coming up a little bit
later today or we'll see you here
tomorrow with all the latest i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo
white house key edited by Adam Tsai
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua Elvira
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you